But here we are with actual actors.
A moderate special effects budget
and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase two.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel revealed more cameos
and returning characters in Deadpool
3 and one of the biggest deep cuts
is Channing Tatum as a version of Gambit.
Also explained
with the plot of his canceled Gambit
movie was before the Fox Disney buyout.
In all the other cameo scenes
that we know about right now.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
It's a bunch of big stuff. Coming up.
We have Loki season two episodes,
so episodes starting really soon.
I'll do videos for everything
You probably saw the news recently
about some of the Deadpool three cameos.
there's so many of them,
like the classic X-Men actors coming
back, classic Fantastic Four actors
like Chris Evans returning as his version
of The Human Torch, Johnny Storm.
Even Ben Affleck's
version of Daredevil is coming back
with Jennifer Garner's version of Elektra.
the list of people
who aren't going to be in this movie
is smaller than the list of people
who are going to be coming back.
the reason why Channing Tatum is Gambit
is probably the biggest cut
that we know about right now is because
his Gambit movie never actually got made
whereas all the other characters
that are coming
back were actually in movies that
we got to see in theaters at some point.
the Gambit movie that almost was Gambit
as a character
has only appeared briefly in live action
theatrical movies.
Most people will remember the Taylor
Kitsch version
of a character from Wolverine Origins,
which coincidentally also starred Ryan
Reynolds as the earlier,
not so great version of Deadpool,
which he clowns on all the time.
the one he later time traveled across
universes
to kill and clean up the timeline.
nice little Loki and Deadpool
three Easter egg.
Now because of the way
things played out in real life,
because a lot of the plot of Deadpool
three is building on what happened
as a result of that and the Loki series
with the TVA and the way
different timelines
work in the Marvel cinematic Multiverse.
So it's kind of a coincidence,
the way things all played out
and they were able to pay this stuff off.
Ryan Reynolds didn't actually do that.
Deadpool two Post-Credits scene,
knowing the way that the Loki writers
were going to explain different timelines
in the way
the Fox Disney buyout was going to go
at the time, they feel that
they didn't know for sure that the foxes
the was actually even going to happen.
The saga of Gambit
in live action actually starts way back
with the original Bryan Singer movies.
Bryan Singer wanted to have Gambit
in the second X-Men movie X2,
still really solid X-Men movie.
he even had James Bamford, who most people
remember from the Arrowverse shows,
who's
actually turned into more of a director.
He did a lot of stunts
to a lot of other TV shows after this
filmed, some test footage
as the Gambit character,
which they ultimately cut
from the theatrical version of the movie.
It was going to happen during the dark
cerebro scene.
while Stryker was trying to force
Professor X to kill
all mutants
with the dark version of Cerebro.
Bryan Singer
wanted to show the effects of dark Cerebro
in all the mutants around the planet.
While this was going on during the scene,
a version of Hank McCoy, a.k.a.
Beast, played by Stephen Bacik,
was seen earlier on television
during the bar scene.
be filmed him at the bar,
writhing in agony, transforming into
his full mutant form
beast form mutant form
in Gambit was going to be shown
playing a card game in the background
with his energy powers
flaring up uncontrollably.
James Bamford
had been working on the movie as Hugh
Jackman's stunt double as Wolverine.
he became the stand in for Gambit
when they were filming that scene.
And for whatever reason, Bryan Singer
just decided to cut it all together.
Just because I think the movie got so big
when they got to x three.
The Last Stand, Bryan
Singer was still attached
to direct the third movie,
at least the beginning.
He was going to get Keanu Reeves
to play a version of Gambit,
but then he eventually left
the project in.
The idea was scrapped.
they decided to save Gambit
for Wolverine Origins, where they cast
Taylor Kitsch,
which everybody saw in theaters
then in 2014, several years later,
Channing Tatum signed on to play
a version of Gambit in X-Men Apocalypse,
after
which they plan to just cut that
and make his gambit solo movie.
Eventually, they just cut him altogether
from Apocalypse.
but this was on the idea
that Fox had already committed
to the Gambit solo movie
and they were just going to treat it
with more reverence.
Channing Tatum talked all about it
for the next couple of years
on all these different press tours
for other movies.
Several directors came and went
because the movie kept
getting delayed for one reason or another.
then after the new Fantastic Four movie
in 2015 tanked, Fox got cold feet
on, doing more their ancillary characters
and decided to completely delay
the Gambit movie for a year.
Other directors came and went again.
Ultimately the delays pushed it
so far out that Disney wound up buying Fox
and an overlap with that.
It was officially canceled by Disney,
not by Fox after the buyout was complete.
When Disney bought Fox,
there have been tons of movies
they had in development that got canceled,
not just Fox Marvel movies,
but regular non franchise movies too.
you remember that Fox
was going to make a Kitty Pryde movie
that was in development.
Brian Michael Bendis
had been working on it that got canceled.
all the future
mainline X-Men movies After Dark.
Phenix also got canceled, too,
originally Channing Tatum's
Gambit solo movie would have featured
the first live action version of Mr.
Sinister as the main villain.
Now, Mr.
Sinister is going to be the main villain
of the upcoming season of X-Men 97.
I literally just did a video about that,
so I'll post a link at the end of this
You also probably remember
all the Easter eggs in the live action
X-Men movies, four versions of Mr.
Sinister that never got paid off.
the X-Men Apocalypse Post-Credits
scene featured Mr.
Sinister Men arriving at Alkali
Lake to clean up the mess from Wolverine's
Weapon
X project and collect DNA samples of his.
The ASICs Corp was for Nathaniel
Essex. Mr.
Sinister, whose real name
when they filmed that post-credits scene,
they intended for it
to set up the Gambit movie.
They would have paid off Mr.
Sinister during that,
another version of live action. Mr.
Sinister was also meant to be
the one behind the evil corporation
controlling the hospital
in the New Mutants movie
that they'd all been trapped
at for research.
another Ethics Corp Easter Egg there.
Originally, Jon
Hamm was going to play live action Mr.
Sinister during a post-credits scene
in that movie too.
but ultimately
they cut that scene at the last minute
because that movie
was one of the other Fox Marvel holdover
movies that overlap with the Fox Disney
buyout Kevin.
Foggy was ultimately forced
to release it during the pandemic.
I remember seeing at a drive in theater
because they weren't allowing people
in regular movie theaters at the time.
it's kind of the same problem
they have with the DC movies.
This year.
There are all these leftover Snyder verse
characters, James Gunn rebooting the DC
movies, recasting everyone.
Mostly you're left with a bunch of movies
based on characters who essentially won't
be canon to the new stuff going forward.
So it's in this weird limbo
state the plot of Channing Tatum's Gambit
movie would have told Gambits Back story
from the comics with Mr.
Sinister in Louisiana before he meets
the other X-Men characters.
he grew up as a thief working for Mr.
Sinister in a gang of mutants
loyal to Essex Corp.
Basically, like his goon squad gambit,
Specialty was stealing things Mr.
Sinister needed for his genetic research
into the gene and mutants.
they got into this during X-Men,
the animated series. Mr.
Senators Main Obsession eventually becomes
the bloodline of Cyclops and Jean Gray,
believing that they could propagate
a superior Omega level mutant, which Mr.
Sinister wants to control himself.
That person wound up
ultimately being Rachel Summers,
who also gets the powers of the Phenix.
But that's why Mr.
Signature is always obsessed with the most
powerful mutants during gambits past.
They would have done
all the dirty stuff Mr.
Sinister had him doing on the daily
with him trying to find a way to get
under his thumb, ultimately
crossing paths with the X-Men Professor X
and they inspire him to finally leave Mr.
Sinister and try to redeem himself.
in I believe the idea with the character
is had they continued with the newer X-Men
First Class line of movies
beyond X-Men Dark, Phenix like had Disney
never bought Fox
and they kept making those original X-Men
movies with those actors
playing the characters.
The next X-Men movie
in the mainline series After Dark, Phenix
would have featured Channing Tatum's
gambit more Recently, the reason
why Ryan Reynolds was able to convince
Channing Tatum to come back
as Gambit is mostly
because they're just friends in real life.
Like he's doing a song for his friend.
They also worked together on his movie
Free Guy a couple of years ago.
He was the avatar of another player
in real life named Revenge.
I mean, Buttons
Shawn
Levy also directed that movie,
and he's directing Deadpool three.
So it's like Channing Tatum reuniting
with his friends, the exact same team to
do something a little bit more them,
allowing him to actually portray Gambit
in real life.
He was a huge fan of the Gambit character
to begin with,
so letting him finally do them in live
action is actually a pretty big deal.
the Free Guy movie is also
how they got Chris Evans
to come back again as his Johnny Storm
from the Fantastic Four movies.
They needed some of those
classic Fantastic
Four actors to come back
because the Deadpool
three movie is kind of doing a version
of Deadpool Kills the Fox Marvel Universe.
Chris Evans did that free guy cameo
for the Captain America jokes
and references
because he was friends with them already.
So it's a pretty easy
slam dunk to get him to come back again
for an even bigger deep
cut to his previous Marvel character
that's how a lot of the weirder cameos
ended up happening in Deadpool three.
Like Ryan Reynolds
is just really good at getting his friends
to come and do quick cameos for fun.
That's how you get Ben Affleck to come
back.
Is his version of Daredevil.
some of the cameos pay off
deeper Easter eggs than others.
Like, for instance,
there's way more meaning behind
the classic X-Men actors coming back
because there's so much X-Men stuff
like Wolverine in the Yellow costume.
in some of those cameo scenes
will come back during secret Wars
in bigger roles like Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is supposed
to have a much bigger role in Secret Wars,
along with Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man,
Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man in probably
some of the other legacy characters.
But the whole idea is that in Deadpool
three, Deadpool winds up
using cable's time
travel device to jump to the 838 universe
unknowingly in in the aftermath of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness,
They'll deal with what happens next after
Scarlet Witch kills most of that team.
part of the idea is that it
becomes a more lawless planet with friends
and allies of those dead Illuminati
team members taking over the team.
that's how they're explaining Ian McKellen
coming back as a version of Magneto,
but a more comic book accurate version
based on X-Men, the animated series
and because of what's happening with X-Men
97 episodes happening pretty soon
to a lot of X-Men,
the animated series Energy in the Air,
they're selling way more merch now.
Do like you can actually buy Magneto's
Helmet from the animated series.
cannot wait
to see all them in more comic book
accurate looking versions of their suits.
cannot wait to see what the post-credits
scenes are going to be.
Just imagine how crazy they're going
to get if all the stuff in the regular
part of the movie is going to be this nuts
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Click here for all my other Deadpool
three videos and click here
for my new Loki Season 2 trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe In maximum effort!